[Music]
okay can you hear me yes okay great so
I'm very sorry that I can't join you
what happened is that I applied for the
European visa waiver program because I
have a new passport and then I had to
fill out a couple of questions one of
them whether I had been in Iran actually
it wasn't Iran last December and they
don't give you feedback about the
success of your application so last
Sunday when I was checking in for my
flight
I couldn't check in and the reason I
found out later is that my visa waiver
has been rejected I suspect it's a it's
because I was on this on this meeting in
Iran so I really regret not to be able
to be with you because there are quite a
number of talks that I would have loved
to see but I'm still somewhat happy that
that I'll be able to give my
presentation and how will you hope to
meet you physically in the near future
okay so what I want to talk about today
is it's in the title control of synaptic
plasticity in the powerful networks okay
you see the slides yes okay great so I'm
going to start with a bit of a detour
can you also see my mouse I made it very
large
okay right so this is sexually where I
come from I'm really interested in
perceptual organization so really how
the brain understands complex pictures
such as this one for instance if you see
this picture you probably don't have a
hard time to see that this and this is
part of the same zebra and and in the
analysis of the visual scene it doesn't
really help that image understanding
starts with fragmentation so neurons low
levels of the visual system have very
tiny receptive fields right that's not
very helpful if you want to see that
this and this is part of the same
perception object now what we have
established in in quite a number of
studies instead what happens in the
visual cortex when you see scene like
this that those image elements that
belong to the object that you're
interested in are labeled by enhanced
neural firing and so basically if this
is if this is the picture that comes in
and if you're interested in the central
zebra the brain creates a representation
where are all those image elements all
those neurons that cause features of the
zebra are interested in have extra
activity okay now how is this related to
plasticity well the proposal that I'd
like to defend today is that those
features those neurons that code
features that are labeled that they are
eligible for plasticity and those
features that have not been labeled then
they are not eligible publicity so
that's basically the bottom line what I
want to pretend today okay so this is
where we come from this shows you the
overview what I would like to talk about
today so I'll give you a very brief
introduction on the on the role of
important feedback connections then I
would like to say a few words about
culture grouping so actually that's
that's where these is labeling
operations that's where we discovered
this happens and then I'm going to
really end on to plasticity so I will
talk about training neural networks and
in the last part of my talk I would also
like to say a few words about what we
have learned
of how this is really implemented in the
brain okay so let's let's start with
support and feedback processing so this
is now very old slide more than 20 to 5
years old now but it's really guiding a
lot of my thinking about how this can
all fit together from family finesse
many years ago so this is the primate
visual system I think most of you know
this slide and also the next one and so
this is if you if you take all the
visual Cordilleras areas you can arrange
them into this hierarchical scheme very
amazing first enters in the primary to
carpet and a sense to go to all these
higher visual areas and we know of
course there are low level areas for
example teachers and higher level areas
complex object categories and so all
these things happens fairly fast now
what an interesting is that this first
fee for processing phase is followed by
a later phase where deeper connections
here in blue and lateral connections in
red come into play they allow for a sort
of recirculation of the activity and
this is actually the face where this
labeling process I was talking about
take place okay now this is actually the
process that psychologists call
selective attention and this labeling of
image elements that they would call
typically object based attention and so
to summarize them based on this scheme
like you can expect from neurons at
different areas so if you have your
electrodes in really with your cortex
then you find many ignorant that
responds to the onset of a stimulus if
you have your electrode in association
cortex you'll find these sensory neurons
but you'll find them intermingled with
neurons that have memory activity so
basically they've reached the time
between a brief sensory stimulus and an
elector response even if the stimulus is
no longer there and then you also find
is neuron that if but I call you're
ramping activity so they might be coding
for a particular feature and they have
extra activity their booster activity
that feature becomes relevant to
behavior if you have you lend your
electrode in frontal cortex you have all
of these as well and then you find
another category of cells that responds
around the time of the movement okay so
for the purpose of my talk today I'll
kind of take all these intricate
complexity and I'll map it down through
this three layers before never so where
it's a sensory layer association cortex
and this is motor cortex and now we do
know that we have these feedback
connections from the motor cortex back
to century areas so as a result of that
you actually might expect to see some of
the selection process also at the level
of early visual cortex and that's what
I'm going to demonstrate even even
memory signals you might expect there
okay because you have this feedback okay
so this is melody the framework that I
like to work in so you can think of this
as a sort of prime maturing machine my
input arrives and if you later goes to
the Association cortex then you out the
output layers of same motor cortex and
it's convenient to think of all these
output neurons as coding for distinct
actions so now one action will be chosen
is sometimes called is a production and
this may stand for an internal action so
it might feed back to updates the
activity here basically will be a shift
of attention it can also be an external
action so say an eye movement or a head
movement so that will have influence of
course on the activity pattern on the
input layer so now you have an update of
the internal state so you get the
different selection signals maybe even
different inputs and then on the next
time step the system might select
another action right updates into
internal States select another action
update its internal state and so forth
so what is of course the challenge for
us is to understand how the network can
learn
to select the right action and also to
update the internal states in in the
most appropriate way
as a result of for instance during
reinforcement reinforcement learning
during feedback about the amount of
reward that is game okay so that's the
thing that that I would like to discuss
today okay now to kind of illustrate
this this idea about 3/4 and feedback
processing our man I make my short
detour on puncture proofing and so I
don't see all of you so this is going to
be a bit of a competition and so what
I'm presenting here is is three dots one
of them is red one is a nice green one
of them is blue and in just a second I'm
going to present two curves now one of
these curves is going to make the
connection between the red dots and
either the green dots or the blue dog so
if you think that the red dot is
connected to the green dot you might
want to raise your left hand
correct blue dot you might want to raise
your right hands okay and I can imagine
you want to be just a little bit faster
than your neighbor okay are you ready
for this 1 2 3 go
okay I see some left hands yes it's left
you go here and then you end up there so
this is the time to take revenge on your
neighbor and so now you want to really
be faster so now we start from this side
are you ready 1 2 3 I see right hands it
takes a bit of time ok so this is I
think an example where you do a lot a
lot of record processing for a very
simple image so what you're doing here
actually is making a number of eye
movements so you typically direct your
gaze to the red to the red dots and then
you're going to make a sequence of eye
movements over this this curve and
eventually you will end up at the blue
dolls
okay but this is a stationary image so
you can only make saccadic eye movements
so what you'll do is move your eyes here
and then you make a second here
now how come you do make a second loop
on the right curve
well basically before you make your
Sakai to do a bit of mental tracing a
lot of this bird then you make your eye
movement then you do a bit of mental
tracing then you make the right movement
then you will be the mental tracing and
so on and so forth and this mental
tracing is actually the updating of the
internal state of your turing machine
and then you make a 92 basic reaction
and so this is how it corresponds to
what I was just talking about how this
is work then well we did we did quite
some work on this task in monkeys so we
asked the animals to look at the central
dots in the center of the screen then
this is a simpler version than you've
just been doing so there are two curves
one of these curves makes a connection
between the fixation point and a larger
red circle that's gonna be the target
for an eye movement and this is a
destructor and then after a delay the
animal now makes an eye you come to the
end of the target curve and what we find
in a stance is kind of interesting so we
typically do multi-units the recordings
from quality implanted electrodes so
this is now the receptive fields and we
are now recording in primary visual
cortex so first part of stage of visual
information processing so here's a
receptive field that's only on the time
curve basically that was mentally
tracing through the receptive field here
the same receptive fields on the
destructor because now the animals
mentally fresh in this group and what we
then see is the following when you
present the stimulus so this is the
first time that something appears in the
receptive fields okay and then you get
your feet forward response this is the
information that is conveyed from the
retina to the cell yes this early face
does not discriminate between a target
and in this person but then you wait a
little bit and then you see that the
text delisted by the target is actually
stronger than that elicited by this
paper so this is recurrent process and
you get the same effect if the two
curves intersect each other so you get
more active theory said
okay so basically what we see here in
this task is that you can see and I've
been showing you all the day that we
have on a basically what you see is that
you get a propagation of the enhanced
activity along this curve so basically
you see the gradual updating of the
internal state of the turing machine
during this task you can read it out
from primarily two parts
now it's also recorded by now from
higher card queries not just primary
visual cortex sp1 we recorded from
before with your high visual area from
two eye fields which is an area frontal
cortex important in generation of eye
movements the receptive fields are
larger in before than they are in v1 and
even larger in frontal cortex and so
here all receptive fields will be on the
target curve here all the receptive
fields would be on the destructor for
now this is a replication of other just
shown you so you get more active in v1
after a delay so this is the recurrent
processor face and before you also get
first the first processing phase that
does not distinguish between target
instructor and then the response
modulation and it's come to I fields you
get to say you get a first face where
and there our response is only
determined by there's something
appearing in the receptive field and
then you have to wait for a couple of
tens of milliseconds if you know that 50
milliseconds or so and then you see that
activity listed by the target curve
becomes stronger than this factor so we
think actually that is this activities
and feedback to lower processing levels
and so the whole brain basically selects
the representations that are being
selected for an eye responds ok so we do
see that basically the selection signal
they are presumably fed back from
frontal cortex that makes the decision
of us to do what to do next - earlier
processing and this is the signal that
we are going to use to give us a much
better plasticity rule that's the area
ok so now I'm going to talk about
plasticity and I want to propose a role
of these feedback connections I was just
talking about
inland and this work was actually
usually inspired by this book that I
guess most of you will know about
certain Umberto published also about
twenty years ago and so now we're going
to talk about this neural network but
now we're going to want to Train it so I
fifty first gets propagated to an outer
layer and I said it before I'm going to
assume now that units in the output
layer that they are coding for distinct
actions now we're going to go to the
reinforcement learning regime so we're
going to assume that the selection of
actions is is a stochastic process so of
course with those output units that have
most activity or most inputs are most
likely to winning this competition so
then since the guess take since the
exodus election is stochastic maybe on
some trial with this stimulus is a team
will win and the network will obtain a
certain amount of rewards on an order
trial with the same stimulus the network
may choose this action receive no
rewards or choose this action and
receive a lot of rewards and over its
experience with the stimulus the network
will build up a certain amount of reward
that it's expected and then we're going
to compute the reward prediction error
right you think it's dopamine but could
also be not a neuromodulator
so if not more reward has been obtained
than what's expected we're going to
release its neural modulator and to
increase the strength of the synapse
between those neurons that were active
thereby increasing the probability that
or the same stimulus is unexpectedly
good action will be selected again again
it's the whole idea and this is fairly
standard in the in the reinforcement
literature
okay now if the network uses an action
that turns out to be disappointing there
will be another neuromodulator
or another concentration of the same
module a neuromodulator
s2
Chris the strength of these centers so
this is fairly standard this is a three
factor learning rule where genetic
changes depend on the activity of a
presynaptic cell on the first method
cell and on the level of the neuro
modulator and that that typically works
fairly well for the second layer of
connections here so here you're going to
increase the strength of this synapse
and in this situation you want to
decrease the strength of these synapses
least here is only pre and postsynaptic
activity so this is the only synapse
that will decrease in strength okay now
you also might want to decrease the
strength of these synapses right and the
problem here is that if you're going to
do that you might also want to decrease
the strength of these synapses because
the pre and post in a 3050 here is the
same as it is here and the level of the
neuromodulator here is also the same as
well but these guys these synapses have
no responsibility for the charge of this
action and the same here you might want
to increase the strength of these
synapses but again then you will also
have to increase the strength of these
synapses alright so the conclusion is
something is missing from this scheme
this is typically known as the credit
assignment and the proposal is that this
is where you can use to fit their
connections and the idea is very very
simple if an action gets selected we
know there are feedback connections we
have to see that they increase the
activity of neurons in visual cortex and
the idea is to use this as as an
eligibility signal so only those
synapses that get the feedback they are
the ones that are allowed to change in
strength here there with decrease in
strength and in the next trial where
this action is selected that is better
than expected then those synapses are
the ones that are going to increase in
strength okay so now you have a
four-vector learning room so we added
the feedback from the response selection
States as a force vector and actually we
have some data from the lab where we
demonstrate that feedback connections
seem to rely to some extent on the
activity of NMDA receptors
which are not to get past ISTE and I
will say a bit more about that in a
little bit later okay now if you don't
do the mouth and then you'll find that
if you if you if you do ride you can
actually get the same synaptic
modifications as are prescribed by air
back propagation if you do stochastic
sampling across the different action
possibilities okay so this is a learning
rule that is by marketing possible we
bleed and that gives you the same
synaptic modifications as arrow break
propagation okay so this is the old idea
we are going to use these feedback
connections to get plasticity
okay now let's give you some intuition
of how this might then work so I'm going
to model this dance that was studied by
Friedman and Assad a couple of years ago
and in their tasks they had monkeys
looking at a dictation point they saw a
cloud of moving dots they were moving in
one of twelve directions and they were
actually separated into two categories
so the motion directions in red he
indicated in red here was there were one
category and those indicated in blue
here they were opposite that green so
then the animal was still my
identification and he had to remember
the category of the of the motion that
you saw and then he saw a second cloud
of moving dots and he had to judge
whether it was the same category or
whether it was the other category if it
was the same category he had to release
a lever if it was a different category
at all the lever and what is nice about
his design is that you can have motion
directions that are from the same
category that are very different and
that you can have motion direction that
are fairly similar but that belong to
different categories effectively
dissociating motion similarity from
category membership okay so and what
that I found recording an area Alafia we
call that Association cortex is that
many neurons there become
two category membership so this is one
example neuron that really likes the
blue motion category so this is a sample
face you see that whenever there was a
sample from the blue motion category
there was pretty good response now the
moment you cross the category boundary
and you go to the red mode you see that
response will drop and to stay low and
in the moment you cross the other
category boundary response will increase
again okay so basically these neural is
neuron was most sensitive to changes in
motion direction that straddles emotions
the category boundary and this is what
they found across quite a number of LEP
neurons that most of these cells were
most sensitive to changes in motion
directions across the particular event
in other words these cells became
attuned to categories okay so how does
the learning scheme that I just proposed
produce such stretchy tuning well I'm
first going to simplify the task
substantially so I'm give you an
intuition of how this might work I'm
going to have a very simple task where
there is simply a cloud of moving dots
and the only thing that I'm not allowed
to say whether it's category one by
making one response or whether it's the
Tegra 2 we're better auto response so
now there's not a necessity to keep the
previous category in working memory and
then make the comparison I will come
back to that later this is the this is a
simple verb okay now here as a neural
network in the input layer neurons that
are tuned to motion direction and so
we're going to present stimulus then we
get the pattern of activity on the input
layer of are defined by the tuning of
their cells
we start with completely random
connectivity so you get some pattern of
activity on the Association layer and
here the output layer and since action
selection is stochastic sometimes the
network will choose category one now
let's assume that this is the right
action so then there will be the
feedback from the response election
today
making some of these support connections
eligible for plasticity sensitivity
neuromodulator and then a neuromodulator
is released it is better than expected
so these synapses that have been tagged
will be increasing in strength okay
now on another trial with the very same
stimulus the never may make an error it
will choose category to other synapses
will be made eligible for plasticity but
now you have the other neuromodulator
are the other concentration of the same
neuromodulator as to decrease the
strength of these synapses okay now what
is nice is that you'll see that such a
simple network will learn such a fairly
simple task in a couple of maybe 100
trials or so and then if you look at
what these units become tuned to that
they are in the association layer you'll
see that they also become sensitive okay
so it will give you some intuition of
how this this will work and it might
work in the cortex and so stitch is
fairly simple learning rule we called it
a Grell we will see that neurons become
too to those features that are important
is dimmers response mapping and neurons
with codes for the Bambi okay so that
that was quite some time ago now we
wanted to to generalize this scheme to
more complex tasks in which you
sometimes have to do quite a number of
actions before you get your reward and
we chose is the legs a cat and second
task because it also has this exclusive
or structure and also requirement to
keep something and working memory so
this is how it works the monkey it is
not stiffly tested in monkeys look at it
looks at fixation point and this is a Q
the Q is either on the left or it's on
the rise then there's a delay so now
them monkey needs to remember the
location of the cube and then as a go
signal the fixation points which is soft
and now the an alliance to make an eye
movements to the remember the location
of the cube on pro psychic trials with
the green fixation point but it actually
has to go to the opposite direction
if it's an anti second with the red
fixation point okay so we want to train
our neural network to solve this task
and now we are not going to give it
reward immediately so now we have to go
to a form of reinforcement learning
where it's possible to delay the reward
and we're going to go to a form of green
for something that's known as cue
learning I think most of you really are
with it for those of you who are not I'm
not sure whether they are in the room
I'll quickly guide you through this so
this is just a task in which you have to
take a number of actions before you can
get your reward so and this is a very
simplified task in which you always
start and stay one you can choose one of
three actions then if you choose action
when you will go to stay - you can
choose two actions now suppose you
choose action - this is actually the
only action that eventually will give
you a reward and of course the challenge
is to learn to take action 1 and state 1
because you're never going to be
confronted with reward immediately after
that action so this is Q learning it was
proposed many years ago where one can
send I am and the trick is that you're
going to remember if you go from stage 2
- action - you have to stumble on the
rewards then you're going to remember
that if you take action - and stay tuned
that actually that has a positive reward
prediction okay so when you store a
positive value for this Q now if I'm in
a later trial you you are in state 1 and
you happen to choose action 1 and you
then go to state 2 where you now know
from here there's a positive few we're
also going to increase if you of the
stage 1 action excellent combination so
basically the network is now
backtracking those state action
combinations that eventually will lead
to reward and it's the only thing that
the network has to learn ok and it turns
out that our our model is completely
consistent with the learning of action
values our Q values actually say ok and
this model is called augment so now
we're going to train it on this delayed
again and saccade task so this is the
network here's the input layer there are
three units
that you are already familiar with it is
kind of hidden units but we now also
introduced a form of a unit that can
memorize activity so if there's a brief
stimulus the unit goes up an activity
and it stays active even if the input is
no longer there sort of an lsdm unit but
it is not any case so it's a very simple
as Tallis TM right so we simply assume
that they exist in the brain of course
we know that there is persistent
activity ok
and actually in the simulations there
will be four of those units with the
memory property ok so this is the actual
simulation so there will be a unit that
computes the Q value for looking
straight ahead so that's at for fixation
there are say units for the Q value for
looking to the left here the network is
actually looking to the left and there
will be a Q value for looking to the
right this is this is the action that is
actually selected by the model so
typically of course it uses the action
with the highest fuel value but it also
needs to explore a little bit then in
the input layer we have a unit that
codes for the green fixation point when
the cause of the red fixation point that
would be in any set at trial required
and a Q on the left and a Q on the right
and we also have an own version of these
input units and a normal unit is when
the fixation point switches on the onion
it is only on four runtimes Devon and
switches off again although the
situation point is still visible so we
know that these this units exist in the
brain there are also of units sewn up
units with for instance responded the
green fixation point appears it doesn't
respond but it only responds the moment
it switches off and we also know that
these of units exist right ok so now we
start with completely random
connectivity this is the number of
trials that have elapsed and let's see
whether this works so basically this is
this is what is visible on the screen so
this is a green fixation point the model
should actually start by attaining
fixation but it is not so this is
actually it is very familiar for those
of you who have trained monkeys so this
is when you bring your monkey the first
day to the lab you analyze no clue
it's just looking around ok so then
after a little bit of experience in this
test this is after 3,000 trials and a
few you'll see that the network now
really starts to develop and the blue
connections are excites 3 and red
connections are inhibitory here and so
this is what happens so you see that the
network manifestation from the peers
typically attains fixation and so this
would be an anti-psychotic trial model
makes a net Sekar this is a pro circuit
trial well it makes a pro circuit this
would be an anti-psychotic trial and
then it's got so it looks good but
actually the model is still making quite
a number of errors this would be an
Eddie Scott trial but it makes a pro
circuit this is a pro circuit trial and
it makes an anti cigars okay so you see
the network gets the structure the time
structure of the test but still makes
quite a number of errors now about 2,000
trials later you'll see that the network
is not perfect
he's always getting it right so this is
a pro circuit trial makes approach the
gas and circuit trial like an ex-con ok
well this goes on and on and so
basically you see now that what an
Epicure and its network somehow it
incorporated all the information that is
necessary to solve this test in this
network has really only 7 Association
humans which would probably increase
number of a little bit so the network
learns to wait for the fixation points
directly to the detection point
wait for the Q remember the location of
the Q and then if you take point
switches off depending on the color of
the fixation point make a pro circuit or
an NTC card so I think it's this is
quite remarkable that such a simple
network with the biologically realistic
learning rule can do all the
things okay now then of course it's
interesting to look what these units
become we come tuned to and this is just
one example of those units that have a
memory property so you see that the
human switches on with the cube so this
base your cue it stays active during the
delay because it has this ability to
maintain activity although there's no
input anymore and then it actually has
an extra boost in activity when the
fixation point disappears and you see
that this cell is less much less active
on the pro circuit transfer desk
some people have called this mix
selectivity that is required to solve
switch next to the border okay so it can
solve this second and see that that's
good what is interesting we can take the
very same network and basically the very
same learning rules simulating
parameters and ability also have the
full version of this delayed mix with
the Tegra toss but can also remember the
category of the stimulus and then also
decides whether a second stone was is
matching or not matching and make the
appropriate response it can do fairly
complex decision-making tasks so this is
a task in which symbols were presented
successively and they gave some
probabilistic evidence whether it would
be a good idea to make and I move into a
green circle or to a red circle this is
another fairly complex task in which
there are two moving sets of dots and
then there was sort of a change in
motion in either location but only the
location at that particular color
methods to the to the monkey and and
these colors were in a rank order so
suppose the rank of red was higher than
the rank of blue then the model should
only responds to motion changes in the
red but the worst
might have been another color say green
that is paired with blue actually would
have been then blue would have been
relevant and then the model should
ignore the green but with attend the
blue and
and so forth right and the mobile learns
there now with some additions and now we
are really needs to include recurrent
connections so also feedback connections
that do not only get past ISTE but also
kind of propagate activity and here we
kind of in this paper we demonstrated
that this is possible actually gives you
an implementation of the so-called
pineda or my des algorithm we can also
train a model using a biologically
possible learning rule to trace a curve
or to do other tasks that require
perceptual organization okay so this is
a fairly general framework that allows
neural networks to many many different
things okay
so now in the last let me see maybe 10
minutes or so I would like to say a few
words about the neurobiology of all of
this so how plausible is this then right
so what we need here is there in
addition to the pre and post activity we
need the gating by neuromodulators and
we need to get the gating of best esteem
and feedback connections now the effect
of neuromodulators I think is fairly
well established and right now I would
like to focus more on this this idea
that the feedback connections gated
plasticity and I know in in the workshop
there are people who also have proposed
there yet so maybe we can we might even
agree on this okay so but this is what I
wanted to show some evidence in favor of
and I want to review data that were from
the group of antelope maths for
Southwest and we know in in the paper
published about four years ago where
they recorded from layer two three cells
in the barrel cortex of rodents and what
they did here is what they call
repetitive whisker stimulation so they
kind of move this whisker alone for some
time and this basically shows how the
information goes from the thalamus then
to an early barrel court exit of course
Anderson layer four and a recorded from
this seven layer two three and basically
what they find is that is repetitive
risk of stimulation increases the
strengths of the Senate between layer
for Allah which is what you see here so
this is to be a synaptic potential and
after a little bit of this rapid
repetitive whisker stimulation see that
the amplitude increases which is also
what you see here okay now since they
have an electrode in the cell they can
also look or this is basically
quantifying the degree of LTP so it
starts at hundred-percent so you get 20
percent extra strength of the PSP's now
here they record it intracellularly and
what they then see is when they kind of
give the rest customers you get this
first early PSP and they get this very
prolonged naba related plateau potential
and they basically find that in the
apical dendrites of these cells there's
a lot of calcium influx now how do they
demonstrate that this is dependent on
NMDA receptors well they can give an
NMDA blocker a 5d ip5 and basically what
you don't see is that is early PSPs
remains but this later plateau potential
disappears okay now they then
demonstrate that actually that this
lates photo potential oh yeah oh yeah
and so to say so if they then block the
end in their receptors maybe not so
surprising they also take out the LTP so
now there's no fastest T anymore like I
said and that's not many expected
someone unexpectedly is dead they
basically find the source of these
battle potentials in a higher-order
selamat nucleus known as p om 2 p om
it's a higher order element nucleus
unlike ppm which is primary in the fetus
and it has a ton of connections back to
as one it has this feedback like
topology those Frenchie's to layer one
now if they knock activity with Massimo
and vom they brought the cells here and
you see that not a plateau potentials
I'm
less pronounced and this manipulation
actually also blocks the LTP okay so
this I think it's direct proof that
feedback connections can get plasticity
of before images okay so this is
basically this is the second point I
wanted to make so now let me then
summarize everything and let me put it
all together so here we have our neural
network did let's focus on the on these
three neurons here and in the
association cortex right so they are
magnified here so activity first gets
propagated from the input layer and the
response is through the Association
layer you see here so the urines that
unit start to echo your spikes and this
is the early phase of the PSP and this
is actually the feed-forward response in
visual cortex I was talking then a
little bit later one of these actions
gets selected and it starts to produce
feedback back to these neurons okay and
we now know that this is associated with
with custom events in the apical
dendrites okay so that's what you see
here tells me pens in you writes and now
we're kind of looking at the late
response of these PSPs and we're looking
at this face where the neural tip these
spiking activity becomes modulated by a
tensor okay now something needs to
happen in this cell to make it fit for
connections eligible for plasticity and
our assumption is that what is produced
here is some biochemical marker that we
call synaptic tag or beautiful business
tech or ineligibility choice press on
his calcium events become replaced by
these tags okay so now the activity is
made the the networks may be doing
something else in the meantime
and may be producing another response
that's going to produce a reward
prediction error and his reward
prediction error now needs to interact
with the cinetic
and if it's better than expected it
needs to strengthen this the strength of
this energy and now the synapse become
stronger okay so this is this is what
you meet okay so to say this is another
way we need two events the first event
is the production of this synaptic tag
or eligibility trace that depends on the
calcium events in the apical dendrites
and there's actually some some nice
evidence of how this might work so this
is from a paper for me Yamashita and in
the group of us I published about four
years ago where they kind of proposed
that but you need hearing in this phase
of the process you need activation of
NMDA receptors calcium include flips
into dendrites
alright so this is now a very very
familiar to us and then a little bit
later you need the reward prediction
error and in this paper actually they
demonstrate that they can even be a
little bit of time between the moments
of this production of this eligibility
trace and the delivery of the open again
that then activates a different pathway
let's start with dopamine it goes
through several intracellular messengers
I clicker MP phosphate kinase a and so
on and so forth and these two pathways
are proposed to converge on the protein
known as cam case two that is now to
fulfill a former honor ed was for her
date itself and together with some
protein synthesis this is then proposed
to give an ink rise to an increase in
synaptic strength okay so this is how it
is all might be together okay but this
is what I wanted to say about the
neurobiology of
so I think that this puts us in a very
interesting place because we now really
start to understand at the molecular
level at the cellular level at the
network level and also a computational
level how all these pieces of the puzzle
fit together allowing the brain to that
has of course many layers beginning with
analysis to give meaningful changes in
the strength of synapses that allow
allows the Turing machine to train
itself ok so few conclusions in the
beginning I posited the country grouping
is associated with labeling of contro
elements with the hands neural activity
and the idea is that this labeling
signal that we know a selective
attention enables plasticity making some
connection sensitive food or a
prediction error you see that how to
conjoin influence of attention and
reward on plasticity allows the
presentation of Arabic propagation in
the biologically possible manner and I
would like to conclude by saying that
these considerations may keep learning
even more relevant for our understanding
of running the brain and these are the
people who contributed to our victim and
expertise were involved in the early
come to a grouping work together with
foci yet our super smiley yes before it
who made the recordings from the
higher-pitched various theoretical works
was started off with - Orion you gotta
read the Lauren Scotland and the augment
model or few learning was done by the
dumbbells together with the sound about
day and the model in which we trains
record networks with biologically
possible algorithm it was done by
Florian rallies and anticodon mom and
the work on how this all fits together
with what we know about the brain was
done together with thank you very much
perhaps the questions one question of
this data of Yashida that you mentioned
there are four particular type of
synaptic connection from cortex to spare
them
so does this fit into the network model
and you kind of reconfigure your network
model that you have no this type of case
this will be only for this type of
synapses yeah here you're mentioning
that this happens in the striatum right
yeah I think that's that's a really
important finding
I would actually suspect that similar
forms of plasticity might also be
happening at cortical cortical synapses
I don't know right so that's that's I
think we start not only have some
insights and how this all might fit
together with there are also many open
questions and I would like to speculate
that these these loops through the
through the striatum and effective
cortex might also play a role in
inference in the persistent in
persistent and producing persistent
activity but for that that's entirely
speculative there is definitely some
some evidence on the roberto lab that
something similar is happening between
thalamus and cortex right there that
produces persistent
yes okay Peter this is on Bartlett Mel I
so there's a little bit of attention
because we've seen presentations about
reinforcement learning on the machine
learning side and there the goal is to
do these extremely difficult it's all
these very very difficult problems that
might require very very deep networks
and we heard Timothy yesterday or the
day before talk about how the type of
algorithm that you're mentioning works
well for small networks and works poorly
for big ones and so I'm kind of just
wondering if a monkey well you know you
have a much better sense of what a
monkey is capable of doing through
reinforcement learning and one question
that I have is do you think that this
type of well relatively shallow learning
thing you you have one layer from what I
can see looks like you have one layer of
weights that are between the inputs and
the outputs that are kind of hidden and
have to be supervised by this
reinforcement do you think that that can
explain essentially what a monkey can
actually do as opposed to say play go or
some other very very complicated tasks
is this going to be enough power is a
small network enough to explain monkey
reinforcement learning so we can
generalize this learning rule to deeper
networks so in principle the answer is
yes and now the question is how how does
it never compare it to learning a monkey
sees the network is about it's difficult
to estimate but typically it's about ten
times as fast as the monkey the monkeys
learn much slower then
but who knows you know maybe these guys
are thinking about the distractor then
of course this place that they see are
much more complex than these highly
abstracted type ability that we provided
to the network so but I guess the good
news is that the the learning rule that
that we have is not much slower than
learning in monkeys and I'm not sure
whether what spinning talked about
welcome Mass gave me a link to a nice
paper that it's on archives where they
really kind of demonstrate that humans
can are actually there so there's a way
of getting reinforcement learning to
also learn faster than then it's
dictated by the more slow synaptic
changes and I think our framework is
quite compatible with that idea so if
for instance if there are two contexts
say there's context a where we're still
was run or requires responsible and
context dear stimulus on which part
responsible then bye-bye kind of
monitoring and representing the error
that you've got on the previous trial
and also memorizing what you just did on
a previous trial you can see actually
quickly to switch context also in a
network like we have so in those
situations a monkey would also actually
learn that there are two contexts and
that and then based on the previous
experience on the last possible trance
it's probably also learn learn which
context he is in in those situation
including making the dialing would also
produce similar result
Marielle to see all of you in the near
future physically so I applied for fees
are now okay